California Governor Gavin Newsom is
ready to reopen shops and schools but
churches are staying closed for the
foreseeable future the reopen plans tell
us a lot about the state of American
Psycho society then Joe Biden gets a big
endorsement from the woman who spent
decades smearing all of Bill Clinton's
sexual victims China faces new
consequences for inflicting this virus
on us and the surprise candidate enters
the race for president all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noll show
[Music]
I need to know before we begin which
politician in America you think has gone
the most insane is it Newsom is it de
Blasio is it Whitmer is it Pelosi which
one has overreached the most let me know
in the comments section I'd be curious
to hear your thoughts I keep going back
and forth we spoke yesterday about my
own governor here in California Gavin
Newsom Newsom just keeps on with the
overreaches the the longer that this
lockdown drags on the more and more the
science shows us that it's time to start
easing up on the lockdown the more the
governor doubles down well the governor
the governor tripled down quadrupled
down yesterday and his plan for how to
reopen in the weeks and months ahead
tells us a lot about our priorities in
in modern American liberal society he
held a big news conference to discuss
his plan now we turn to Governor Newsom
in 87 and we released this for the most
accomplished album I think their
undisputed masterpiece is hip to be
square song so catchy
people probably know listen to the
lyrics but they should because it's not
just about the pleasures of conformity
and the importance of friends it's also
a personal statement about the band
itself
[Music]
I'm sorry I got confused again that was
actually Patrick Bateman from American
Psycho it's sometimes I confuse the two
try getting a reservation at Dorsia now
Newsom 2024 it's going to be the
campaign slogan here is the actual clip
of governor Newsom explaining his
four-part plan for reopening we believe
we are weeks not months away from making
meaningful modifications to that
indicator and in this space weeks not
months you'll ask me well as weeks one
week or three weeks weeks not months
again based upon the data based upon the
indicators so weeks not months well that
sounds pretty good doesn't it okay good
maybe governor Newsom is listening to
reason here maybe after this
unprecedented draconian shutdown that
does not appear to have been backed up
by a whole lot of evidence that does not
appear to have accomplished much at all
may have cost more lives than it
actually saved very likely may have cost
more lives than it saved now it's gonna
be weeks not months right mm not so fast
because Gavin Newsom is is going to
reopen the California economy fifth
largest economy in the world in a series
of phases so what opens we're in phase
one right now what opens in Phase two
then what opens in Phase three
then what opens in phase four tells you
everything you need to know about the
governor's priorities so that's phase
one and phase two again retail logistics
manufacturing non-essentials schools
that we begin in the summer and
preparation the early falls childcare
facilities and centers with strict
physical distancing and environmental
considerations that had work force
protections customer and consumer
protections there's a third and fourth
phase just four phases the third phase
is personal care it's the areas around
you know well a lot of discussion around
gyms and spas and nail salons and people
want to get haircuts all of us those
would fall into the third
Fay's category dr. angel again will lay
out some details on that and then of
course ultimately the fourth phase which
are these highest risk activities not
the higher risk activities in stage
three
the highest risk activities that's the
larger public venues the conventions the
concerts the larger entertainment venues
with crowds that would be in that
category
notice anything missing there what about
the churches you've got retail shops and
schools and daycare okay and then we've
got the hair salons and the nail salons
and the gyms and we got the concerts and
the big sporting events what about the
churches doesn't even cross his mind
does it now you might think okay if
they're gonna open the schools probably
that's about the time they're gonna open
the churches right you'd be wrong we
will get to where the churches fall in
all of this in the open order and in our
social priorities but first I gotta
thank our friends over at ready wise you
know having enough food to last you in
the event of a real food emergency is
sort of like insurance right and it can
save you and your loved ones and maybe
now more than ever you're thinking about
that well our sponsor you know wise
company they recently changed their name
to ready wise and now is a better time
than ever for you to be ready with
long-term nutritional food options
ready wise has options like emergency
meals free freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition new adventure meals for hiking
camping other outdoor activities ready
wise meals are easy to prepare you just
add water they also have a very long
shelf life
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you order online you have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep that probably sounds
pretty good right about now they use the
finest ingredients and latest food prep
technology to ensure optimal taste and
freshness okay each meal is a
combination of both dehydrated and
freeze-dried ingredients they're packed
into durable long lasting patches check
it out right now get free shipping at
ready wise calm when entering Knolls at
checkout or by calling 855 four five
three twenty nine forty five ready wise
has a 90 day no questions asked return
ballast
so there is no risk taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family prepared today and do it today
ready wise or EAD y-wis EECOM promo code
Knowles to get free shipping so newsom
forgot to mention the churches when he
talks about reopening we're in stage one
right now
which is basically just a total shutdown
stage two opens up schools child care
facilities retail businesses for
curbside pickup but still reopens the
retail businesses and offices where you
can't work from home these offices are
going to be reopened to have employees
there that's stage 2 the churches don't
open until stage 3 stage 3 includes hair
salons nail salons gyms movie theaters
and in-person religious services
churches and weddings so let me get this
straight we can reopen the schools we
can reopen the daycare centers within
weeks but we can't reopen churches for
months he says the schools will be weeks
not months he says the churches will be
months not weeks but the the virus is
just as virulent at school as at church
just as contagious at school as it's as
at church if governor Newsom wanted to
open up the churches he easily could do
that
but he's not gonna be opening up the
churches any time soon because he
doesn't want to open up the churches and
I know exactly what he's thinking I know
what every secular modern liberal in
America is thinking they're thinking oh
we got to open up these schools we gotta
open up the schools because right now
parents have to look after their kids
and they haven't made accommodations to
look after their kids we've got a modern
economy where everyone's working all the
time so they can't look after their kids
some people can't even feed their kids
or maybe they can't feed their kids but
they choose not to feed their kids they
rely on the government to feed their
kids and so it's just such a hassle we
got to find somewhere to put these kids
so we got oh yeah we got to put them in
school or we got to put them in daycare
ASAP but nobody has to go to church
right nobody I know some like silly old
women
who were afraid of the dark I know that
they like to go to church but okay
you don't nobody's got to go to church
right what happens it sure it's nothing
a bunch of hocus-pocus superstition so
we're gonna keep that closed as long as
we can because you know we all want the
virus to spread but the schools the
schools we have to open the schools they
think it's not important to go to church
they think nothing really happens it's
just this old silly custom that people
have that if the government could shut
it all down tomorrow they would because
then they'd have fewer virus is
spreading around but they can so anyway
we'll put we'll just put that off for a
few months now someone tweeted when I
pointed this out someone tweeted at me
and said oh my gosh Michael you're so
crazy you think that going to church is
as important as going to school and
that's not true that's not what I think
I think that going to church is much
much more important than going to school
okay go to church get eternal life mmm
that's pretty good that's that's pretty
good right go to school learn about 56
imaginary genders mmm I've got to make a
choice there I'm probably going with the
church right go to church access the
sacraments worship God contemplate the
most profound mysteries of God and man
the received wisdom of all the ages go
to school learn about how George
Washington was a racist and like really
bad and stuff mmm okay I think I'm gonna
go a little bit more on the church side
of things this is I don't just mean to
make fun of Newsome or kind of modern
liberals it actually tells us something
profound about it this is the priority
of a liberal Society of a modern liberal
society it's all just about material
stuff it's all just about very practical
utilitarian knowledge we don't
contemplate the eternal questions we
don't view ourselves as eternal
creatures we don't view the deeper
spiritual questions that mankind has
contemplated for all of history what the
hell does this tell us about our society
that we're not in a very serious place
okay Christians were not the only
targets though of these power-hungry
politicians Bill DeBlasio in New York
sends out this tweet
quote my message to the Jewish community
and all communities is this simple the
time for warnings has passed I have
instructed the NYPD to proceed
immediately to summons or even arrest
those who gather in large groups this is
about stopping this disease and saving
lives period now I assume that tweet was
just a translation from the original
German that mayor de Blasio gave that
out in what a terrible look de Blasio
New York I guess has had some trouble
shutting down the synagogue's because
the Jewish community there realizes that
these religious questions and the
religious fact of life is much more
important than going to retail shops
much more important than being able to
give your kids to someone else to watch
all day long right liberal society
doesn't think that way but traditional
religion does think that way we think
it's much more important to deal with
the spiritual reality of man than to
deal with these physical needs but
liberal society just says the most
important thing to do is to consume
you've got to consume products all that
you've got to be able to go to retail
shops how would we survive if we can't
consume products and you've got to be
able to indoctrinate the next generation
to perpetuate the system those are the
two things you're not the kids aren't
learn it's not like they're receiving a
classical education at school it's not
like they're receiving a proper liberal
arts education they're just learning the
faddish ideologies of the regime about
climate change environmentalism about
the gender theory about all these sort
of things that perpetuate liberal
modernity and the eternal questions not
only are they not contemplated they're
not allowed to be contemplated you're
not allowed to even read the Bible in
schools which is the most important book
ever written that that shaped our entire
culture and de Blasio obviously is
playing his part in that as a good
modern leftist now at the same time as
the the mayors and the governor's and
and the kind of liberal elite are
doubling down on everything the New York
Times is admitting that actually maybe
the lockdowns aren't having that big of
a health effect at all there's this
article that comes out from of all
places the New York Times
New York Times says life has to go on
how's Sweden has faced the virus without
a lockdown you remember basically every
country in the world shut down total
lockdown crash the global economy except
for Sweden those Swedes weren't going to
hear it they basically stayed open so
the New York Times has to admit now the
country was an outlier in Europe
trusting its people to voluntarily
follow its protocols many heaven but it
does not seem to have hurt them
Swedes they said could be trusted to
stay home follow social distancing
protocols and wash their hands to slow
the spread of the virus without any
mandatory orders and to a large extent
Sweden does seem to have been as
successful in controlling the virus as
most other nations so then what have we
been doing for the past five weeks if
the lockdowns have not put us in a much
much better position than no lockdowns
at all that we see in Sweden what's the
point of the lockdowns because by the
way when the virus comes back again
which it will especially since we don't
have a vaccine in sight Sweden is gonna
be in a much better position because
they're going to have what is called
herd immunity or something close to it
by the time it comes back again that's
the whole point of not locking down
times goes on to admit while other
countries were slamming on the brakes
Sweden kept its borders open gatherings
of more than 50 people are banned but
that's about it there are almost no
fines and police officers can only ask
people to oblige
that's it and yet Sweden is doing just
fine
so while not not just the many studies
that we've talked about on this show
over the past few days and weeks not
just the many models that we've looked
at that haven't come true the Domesday
models 2 million Americans dead 4
million Americans did doesn't look
anything like that as all of the
scientific evidence falls apart for the
lockdowns the liberal elites the mayors
and the governors and the journalists
double down actually even at the New
York Times the putative Lea conservative
columnist there Ross Douthat
tweeted out
this hot take on the lockdowns quote the
fact that Sweden and parts of the US
right have converged on the same let the
old die for herd immunity approach to
the coronavirus demonstrates that Nordic
socialism and American libertarianism
are the twin faces of late liberalism
siblings not enemies
send tweet who's got this little kind of
joke at the end send tweet here's the
first thought that pops into my mind now
the point that Ross Douthat made is
almost a good point it's kind of the
point we made yesterday that there's
this similarity between hyper
individualistic libertarianism and
statist liberalism that actually they're
kind of two sides of the same coin sure
I guess that points right the trouble is
what he's observing about what's
happening is wrong he's saying that
Sweden and parts of the US have
converged on a let the old die for herd
immunity approach well that's not what
his own newspaper is saying about what's
actually happening nobody is suggesting
let the old die for herd immunity what
we're suggesting is there's there's no
alternative to the virus working its way
through the society and there's no
advantage to the lockdown because we
were told to it there are two points of
a lockdown don't overwhelm the health
care system by enough time to get a
vaccine we now know we're not going to
get a vaccine any time soon we know that
the virus is spreading very very quickly
much faster than people predicted it
would and we know that we're not
overwhelming the hospital system saw it
even in New York which was the epicenter
in the United States
so the lockdowns aren't accomplishing
anything we know people are dying from
the lockdowns
people always die when you crash the
economy so we're just saying a lot
there's no point to the lock downs the
lock downs are causing more harm than
good that's not this difficult you know
let the old die so that young people can
make more money that's just a fiction
that's a fiction now being promulgated
by people who got it wrong in the first
place they got the lockdowns wrong even
when many of us were saying hey maybe we
should slow down maybe we shouldn't pump
the globe pump the or drive rather the
global economy to a crash okay I get it
people don't like to be wrong they hate
it when the evidence disproves what they
were saying people have got to move on
oK you've got to react to the evidence
in front of you you can't become so
wrapped up in your own ideology that
you're ignoring the evidence all around
you I mean I think we're seeing a lot of
that about our even just our culture
forget about coronavirus for a moment
the fact that this country which was
founded on religious liberty which was
founded because pilgrims religious
zealots from England sailed across the
ocean so that they could practice their
own very peculiar form of Christianity
left everything that was known about
civilization and came to a wilderness in
the in the Northeast in New England to
practice their own very odd form of
Christianity and that many other
religious groups have done that and that
our our first amendment gives us certain
religious liberties that the country has
this religious ethos the fact that we
now think it's more important to be able
to drop your kids off at daycare and go
consume products at retail stores than
it is to go to church the fact that now
our governors think there's no it
doesn't really matter if you go to
church that tells us that something has
broken in our culture as actually
there's a film out right now brand-new
film it's just on Amazon Prime was
supposed to go to South by Southwest
it's about this question it's about how
our culture has changed how it's being
reflected on the internet that movie is
called that feel when no girlfriend TFW
no GF and it's about kind of 4chan
Internet me me in the cell is the term
media use world that has been created on
the internet because of the alienation
and the isolation of modern liberal
society we'll get to that in just a
little bit when your culture does not
match your ideology when the reality
does not match what you think about
reality you should change your mind
because reality is probably the the
thing to rely on we're seeing this even
in sports I know that there's not a lot
going on in sports right now but there
is a story a Patriots rookie kicker Skye
Justin wore Wasser is now being publicly
shamed because he has a tattoo in
support
the American Revolution that's how much
our culture has been worked we'll get to
that in a second first I have got to
thank our friends over at ring you know
how much I love ring especially now
right now especially you want to know
who's at your door whether or not you're
at home you might be at home maybe
you're running out to one of the few
places you're allowed to go to maybe you
are able to go back to work we're home
more than usual these days but it's hard
to keep a close eye on things more
deliveries mean more boxes left
unattended more opportunities for
packages to go missing with ring you can
keep your home safe no matter where you
are I love ring especially now sweet
little lease is a good shot you know but
I like to be able to keep an eye on my
place I love it so much I trust it so
much that I actually now give this out
as a gift to my friends when they have a
housewarming or something like that we
just saw on the camera the other day
some people have been stealing packages
around the building probably wouldn't
have been able to see that if we didn't
have a little camera out there to record
it ring it gives you protection at every
corner
doorbell three is upgraded with
additional security features and works
on any home get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit right now when you go
to ring comm slash Knolls
the welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell three and chime Pro it's all
you need to start building custom
security for your home today go to ring
comm slash Knolls that's ring comm /
Knolls you know that I don't know
anything about sports but I do know
something about how the American culture
has changed and we're seeing that now in
sports this Patriots rookie kicker
Justin wore Wasser he has this tattoo
and it has the number three and some
stars and stripes on them and this
refers to this idea that only 3% of
Americans in the Revolutionary War
fought for the Patriots side and the
rest were either neutral or they
supported the British or they wouldn't
actually put their money where their
mouth is and stand up against British
tyranny this is an idea that's got long
standing in American history and then
this idea of the 3% came up during the
Tea Party movement over the last 1012
years or so so this rookie kickers got
that little tattoo on and now the
American culture is trying to shame him
tell him that that's actually racist and
bigoted and evil and terrible and
awful if he identifies with the American
Revolution so he was brought on a local
news program and he was basically just
bullied into removing the tattoo here's
Row Wasser I on to Twitter and I I saw
the tweet I saw that someone had taken a
picture of me and put it with you know
my tattoo and linking me to some
horrific events you know obviously
Charlottesville and these horrible
things no no never
it was you know the first time I found
out what it was linked to was on on
Saturday and that's that's why I was you
know so that's that's why it was so
surprising when did you get the tattoo
yes well when I was 18 I got it and it
is described to me as you know the
percentage of colonists that rose up
against the authority of the British wow
that's such a you know American
sentiment a patriotic sentiment and I'm
coming from a military family yeah I
thought that really spoke to me and I
you know I I always was proud to be an
American I'm very proud ah that's the
problem you're not allowed to have any
feeling of loyalty to your country
anymore that's the problem
listen to the way this is being framed
same wool did you know that you're
actually a racist neo-nazi skinhead all
right fascist terrible person when you
got that tattoo and the guy goes no
didn't know that I thought it was the
American Revolution and the
three-percent the foot the British and I
love my country and I've got a lot of
military members in my country and I'm
not a bad guy
what I'm not allowed to support the
American Revolution anymore and no
you're not the way they link it they're
talking about all these awful bigots and
people and events well I did a little
look into the 3% thing I mean it's a
totally disparate group of people so
it's you know people can wear it not
even know that there
the organizations called the
three-percent but I said okay maybe look
maybe the three-percent organization is
actually a bigoted terrible hate group
well I looked into it and after
Charlotte's ville you know after the the
alt-right
rally at Charlotte's ville there was a
group of the three-percent people which
is the National Council and they said
explicitly we will not align ourselves
with any type of racist group for the
you know if one or two people who have
the 3% tattoo showed up to this thing
they shouldn't do it don't do it we
don't support this we disavow it and yet
this guy is being shamed for it that's a
strange culture I mean now that wouldn't
have happened fifty years ago if you
said fifty years ago yeah I really
support the American Revolution you
would not have been shamed out of
football but now football isn't is an
anti-american activity right we now have
league-wide protests of the american
flag
not just league-wide protests of the
cops not just league wide protests of
the military not just league wide
protests of donald trump league wide
protests of the american flag which is
the symbol of the country itself in our
sporting events and sports are always
patriotic that is in the nature of games
of sports something has gone terribly
wrong here and it's gone terribly wrong
in recent years something is going a
little bit psycho in our culture we will
get to that
speaking of psychos in our culture
Hillary Clinton just endorsed Joe Biden
there's no better way to get yourself
out of sexual assault allegations than
to have the the woman who smeared all of
Bill Clinton's victims have her come out
and endorse you right that's pretty
smart we will get to that in a moment
first got to thank our friends though
the Benham brothers you know the Bennet
brothers when you start to have your
employees working remote you've got to
manage your workforce and your work flow
really really well okay obviously this
virus is having a big impact on small
businesses and on employees or its
systems are crucial the Benham brothers
are great at managing work teams that
are all over the country these guys have
over a dozen businesses including a real
estate empire that span
over 35 states now you might have heard
of the Benham brothers before one cuz I
tell you about them and two because they
were slated for a reality TV show on
HGTV that was cancelled because of their
commitment to conservative values I
really like these guys in over the last
six months they've created a new course
called expert ownership how to own a
business without it owning you I love it
you know one real problem is about our
liberal modern culture is this idea that
all you have to do your whole life long
is just hustle hustle hustle
forget about virtue forget about
character forget about morality just you
hustle and then you hustle yourself into
the ground well that's not the Benham
brothers approach all right they
understand that life is about more than
that
they have slashed the cost of this
course to help small business owners and
entrepreneurs who are trying to navigate
all this happening right now head on
over to Benham brothers dot-com slash
Knowles to see a preview of the course
and get a special discount that's benh
am brothers comm slash Knowles came to
wles
right now when you join daily wire when
you become an insider plus or all-access
member what do you get you get one
tumbler you can't just have one tumbler
not these days too many tears you got to
get to you got to get one for Gavin
Newsome you got to get one for Bill
DeBlasio once our country actually
reopens more cars on the road every day
because people are not having any of
this okay head on over to daily wire.com
subscribe we will be right back
Joe Biden is breaking out the big guns
he's breaking out Hillary Clinton which
I guess could literally refer to guns
you know you don't want to end up on the
wrong side of Hillary Clinton allegedly
allegedly look I'm not making any claims
okay Hillary Clinton is now coming out
and supporting Joe Biden I'll give it to
you in her own words to send a message
to every survivor of sexual assault
don't let anyone silence your voice you
have a right to be heard and you have a
right to be believed oh no I'm sorry
that's an old clip that was after
Hillary spent decades smearing her
husband's sexual victims and before she
endorsed an increasingly credibly
accused possible sexual assault on past
that now now she is endorsing a Joe
Biden and why is Hillary endorsing Joe
Biden what's the point of endorsing Joe
Biden she actually says the part that
you're not supposed to say out loud she
says like so many other liberals and
leftists say that you should never let a
crisis go to waste
but this is also a really high stakes
election and every form of health care
should continue to be available
including reproductive health care for
every woman in this country and then it
needs to be part of a much larger system
than eventually and quickly I hope gets
us to universal health care so I can
only say amen to everything you're
saying but also to again enlist people
that this would be a terrible crisis to
waste as the old saying goes we've
learned a lot about what our absolute
frailties are in our country when it
comes to health justice and economic
justice so you know let's be resolved
that we're gonna solve those once you're
elected president there is the logic the
reason to endorse Biden is not because
Biden is gonna make some great President
Joe Biden looks like he's falling asleep
during her endorsement if you watch the
clip the reason to endorse Biden is
because this is a good
opportunity for a Democrat to win the
economy has crashed because the
government made it crash and so it's a
good chance and Joe is the only chance
they've got so okay we're gonna go and
endorse Joe Biden obviously some people
are not thrilled about this endorsement
namely Tara Reid the woman who is
accusing Joe Biden of sexual assault
decades ago here's what Tara Reid had to
say about the endorsement quote I voted
for Hillary Clinton in 2016 I voted for
her in the primary I'm a lifelong
Democrat but yet what I see now is
someone enabling a sexual predator and
it was my former boss Joe Biden who
raped me Hillary Clinton has a history
of enabling powerful men to cover up
their sexual predatory behaviors and
their inappropriate sexual misconduct we
don't need that for this country we
don't need that for our new generation
coming up that wants institutional rape
culture to change she added I will not
be smeared dismissed or ignored I stand
in truth and I will keep speaking out
now look a pretty strong statement
obviously much more credible than other
accusations we've heard against other
politicians we'll get to the comparison
in a moment but she's making some pretty
serious claims don't forget we didn't
hear anything about this publicly for
decades then initially when she came out
about a year ago she said Joe Biden just
sort of made her uncomfortable that he
was inappropriate was very vague then
she said that he sexually assaulted her
and now she's saying he raped her those
are those are different things right I
mean it's he he didn't go all the way in
terms of the the accusation that she's
making or at least has been making over
the last month or so but he did he did
he did do the thing that act i rana Clee
democrats were upset that Trump joked
about he grabbed her by the you know
where and you know the Democrats spent
four years complaining the Trump joked
about that now you've got a guy being
accused of actually doing that then Tara
Reid goes on and says that we have a
rape culture that is a claim that I
don't think very many people would agree
with that there's a rape culture in
America that the campus of Harvard
University is actually more dangerous
for women than downtown Baghdad or
something I don't I don't think people
really believe that so we have to keep
perspective we don't want Republicans to
just be like Democrats and use this as
pure Craven opportunism
however there is some evidence to back
up this woman's claims first of all Joe
Biden in trying to answer these charges
defending the Hillary Clinton
endorsement answering the allegations
against him he just as usual keeps
putting the foot his foot in his mouth
imagine the worst phrasing to use if you
are trying to change the subject from
the sexual assault allegations against
you back to a political issue like the
economy imagine the worst possible word
choice that's what Biden gives you I
would get much more engaged in the world
we can't step back if in fact for
example we solve the problem in the
United States America and you don't
solve it other parts of the world you
know what's gonna happen we're gonna
have you're gonna have travel bans
you're gonna not be able to do have
economic intercourse around the world
there's a lot look when America goes
alone when America's first is America
alone economic intercourse you are
trying to change the subject from the
sex stuff about you you're trying to
turn it back to the economy which is not
particularly sexy that's probably a good
idea turn it back to that and so you use
the phrase intercourse that's not even a
phrase people use but Joe Biden just
can't help himself the only reason that
he can get away with it the reason he's
so comfortable getting away with it is
he knows that the media won't cover it
how long have these allegations been out
now weeks months and yet the mainstream
media will not cover it actually the the
nearest thing we got to anyone covering
it was on Telemundo in Spanish el apoyo
jayega
el momento okay a Biden is another poor
Delaware in franca acusaciones de asalto
sexual de parte de un empleado de su
oficina cuando el agua de como senadores
la de cada de los noventa my Spanish is
not exactly great but sounds like
they're talking about how a former
staffer is accusing him of these sexual
allegations you don't see that on CNN
you don't see that on MSNBC you don't
see that on all the stations that aired
weeks and weeks of 24/7 coverage over
Christine Blasi Ford and Julie sweat
Nick and Michael avenatti all accusing
justice Brett Kavanaugh you
see that at all University of Delaware
is covering this up to University of
Delaware has Joe Biden's papers so if
there are documents pertaining to the
firing or the departure of this woman
Tara Reid from the Biden's staff if
there are documents pertaining to any
kind of settlement or the allegations
themselves they're probably at the
University of Delaware University of
Delaware won't open them up they say the
Senate documents are housed by the
University of Delaware library they
cover a wide swath of Biden's political
career but they are being kept secret
until he retires from public life why is
that probably because there's something
little dodgy in there some some ammo for
his political opponents now the would-be
vice presidential candidate Stacey
Abrams for her part is defending Joe
Biden here is our future imaginary vice
president who's the current imaginary
governor of Georgia Stacey Abrams okay
someone who wants to be his vice
president I think it's important that
you we speak about something that's in
the news now okay hold on first one
second I gotta take a break there she's
known as the person who wants to be vice
president she's not known as a governor
of Georgia cuz she's not the governor of
Georgia she's not the state
representative in Georgia she's the
woman who wants to be vice president I
love that that is basically the
beginning in the end of her reputation
they go on as you know there is a sexual
assault allegation against Joe Biden the
accuser name is Tara Reid tells CNN that
the alleged incident happened in 1993
while she was working as an aide and
Biden Senate office she is claiming that
she was delivering Biden a duffel bag
and says it Biden had her up against the
wall in a corridor on the hill and
violated her with his fingers now CNN as
Knapp has now spoken on the record with
her former neighbor who says Reid told
her about the allegation within a few
years of the alleged incident Biden's
campaign says untrue never happened
is this a credible allegation I believe
that women deserves to be heard and I
believe that they need to be listened to
but I also believe that those
allegations have to be investigated by
credible sources the New York Times did
a deep investigation and they
found that the accusation was not
credible I believe Joe Biden I believe
that women need to be believed and heard
but just not women who accused Democrats
because the Democrat Party newspaper
said that she's a liar so she's a liar
and that's why I support Joe Biden this
woman the cojones on this woman or
astounding I love her I hope she gets
the running mate nod I hope that she's
gonna be around on the national
political scene for months and months
she is the gift that keeps on giving
here's what Abram said when Kavanaugh
was accused in in a much less credible
way she says quote after the courageous
and compelling testimony from dr.
Christine Blasi Ford yesterday it is
shameful the Cavanaugh's nomination is
being rushed forward I believe women and
I believe survivors of violence always
deserve to be supported and to have
their voices heard let's just do a
little side-by-side comparison Christine
Blasi Ford had no documented
relationship with Brett Kavanaugh
whatsoever
okay nothing linking those two people
ever couldn't name the location or the
date of the alleged incident of the
party at which this incident took place
couldn't say who was at the party
changed her story multiple times finally
when she did name a friend who was at
the party the friend said it didn't
happen that she didn't see it happen
couldn't couldn't corroborate anything
didn't have a single person to
corroborate any part of the story which
had changed many times over the years
got caught in multiple lies as well some
of which had to do with strange details
like the architecture of her own house
which she said related to this incident
nothing about her story held out and she
was by far the most credible accuser
against Brett Kavanaugh compare that to
terror Reid we know she had a
relationship to Biden because we know
she worked on his staff her mother
called in to the Larry King show the
very month that she left the Biden staff
and talked about some kind of incident
involving a prominent US Senator tear
Reid has a specific allegation that has
not changed all that much and Tara Reid
has corroboration from a friend at the
time we talked about her yesterday the
friend said this did happen Tara Reid is
much much much more credible than
Christine Blasi Ford the allegations
against Biden are much much much more
credible than the allegations against
Brett Kavanaugh it is a scandal of the
highest proportions that the mainstream
media are trying to bury this story that
the New York Times is calling this woman
a liar that CNN and MSNBC will not run
it and that absolute cynical hacks like
Stacey Abrams and Hillary Clinton and
every other member of the Democratic
Party are are saying that this woman is
not telling the truth okay my standard
of Justice is not believe all women or
believe all men it's follow the evidence
and give the accused due process that's
not the left standard of justice they
pretend to be defenders of women and
then they throw them under the bus and
we knew this during the Clinton era cos
Hillary was the one who did it
and then I guess some people forgot it
for a few years but it seems to me we're
remembering this again BuzzFeed right
now has a piece out they got the scoop
that the Biden campaign is circulating
talking points to tell the surrogates to
to say that this woman should not be
believed okay not a great look for his
campaign but it does expose something
about her or cynical political culture
now speaking of our cynical political
culture there's a new candidate who's
running for president that candidate
he's not left-wing he's not right-wing
he is the libertarian Justin Amash who
is a showboater who is the only
Republican in the house who voted to
impeach Trump he's just a big jerk I
mean he's just a showboating jerk and
the sad thing about his campaign is that
not even his own supporters support him
so you know the bulwark is the kind of
leftist conservative outlet I know that
sounds odd but it's a it's a I guess a
fairer way to put it as a liberal
conservative outlet there on the the
liberal wing of the Republican Party
they have now put out this piece because
that a lot of these people with the
bulwark would support again
like Justin Amash but they don't like
him because they think he's going to
take votes away from Joe Biden and they
want Joe Biden to be Donald Trump
conservatism so this is the peace
headline Justin Amash should not run for
president in 2020 uh Amash is great but
a third party run could help reelect
Donald Trump we love Justin Amash we're
what the kids would call a mosh stands
here's the only two people on planet
earth who are fans of Justin Amash I
suspect including Justin Amash we love
him because he's the only member of the
freedom caucus who didn't abandon
everything he believed to pledge fealty
to Trump yeah that's right he just voted
to impeach a fairly conservative
president one of the most conservative
presidents we've ever had in our
country's history to be clear this isn't
an easy call on the one hand we want to
be for him to have the joint
satisfaction of getting behind the
constitutional superhero of our dreams
but on the other hand there is a
downside risk to his running and the
price of a second Trump term is too
great for anyone to be playing dice with
him I'm not going to go too hard at the
authors of this piece because I've
worked with one of them on a campaign
one time so I my point is not to make
fun of them it's to make fun of Justin
Amash this is what happens when you let
your ideology run away from reality
Donald Trump is the most conservative
president we've had in decades and
decades and in by a certain light
probably the most conservative president
we've had since Calvin Coolidge and yet
because people have gotten so wrapped up
in their liberal ideology even people on
the right have gotten wrapped up in a
liberal ideology they've made an idol
out of that ideology and they can't see
the disconnect of that ideology to the
culture even as things go off the rails
in our society even as we prioritize
retail businesses over going to church
even as we prioritize sjw's and leftism
over the American Revolution even as we
prioritize some show voting wacko Justin
Amash over an actual conservative
president that's a big trouble that's
been going on you know we had we had
this liberal ideology you I guess you'd
called neoliberal ideology globalist
ideology over the past few decades which
cheered on the rise of China now guess
what happened China is infiltrating our
media it bought off all of Hollywood
it's infiltrated our institutions of
higher learning
especially Harvard and it caused this
global pandemic and it caused the
pandemic even ignoring the origins of
the virus which seems to have a link to
the Wuhan Institute of biology that
government lab just the cover-up alone
is what caused the pandemic and some
people are still stuck in their ideology
they say well rising rising tide lifts
all ships even when it comes to
geopolitical adversaries like China
fortunately some people are pushing back
so right now there's some concrete steps
I spoke to Senator Ted Cruz about this
on our show together verdict with Ted
Cruz which will be coming out soon but
he is putting forth specific legislation
and regulations that will stop China
from broadcasting a TV station into the
United States to air their propaganda
that will stop China from infiltrating
Hollywood or at least slow it down a
little bit that's the script act that
will knock a major Chinese spy company
I'm sorry I mean a telecommunications
company called Huawei out of the West
where it's infiltrating the West a lot
and where it will reduce Chinese
influence and elite American
universities I recommend you go check
out the verdict podcast when that comes
out we'll go into more detail there I
think this is going to be the challenge
but you know zooming out a little bit
when we're talking about coronavirus
when we're talking about the 2020
election when we resume at a little bit
more we just look at our culture right
now in the Trump era or the post Trump
era where we go from here we have all
been in thrall to a sort of particular
liberal ideology Democrats and
Republicans in many ways left and right
in many ways have been pushing into this
ideology of globalism neoliberalism
liberal modernity use whatever whatever
ISM you want to describe it but it's had
some effects that are not so great it's
made us all richer right all that trade
with China it has it isn't way made us
richer because we had cheaper consumer
goods all this kind of hyper
individualism has made us richer where
we feel sort of unleashed to go pursue
our own interests and yet a lot of other
aspects of society have crumbled
American solidarity feeling of loyalty
to your countrymen feeling of loyalty to
the founding of your country you know
the American Revolution a lot of that
has fallen apart a feeling of
solidarity to your church communities
which now are being shut down so that
you can just go shop more instead
because that's more important a
grounding of our politics in the eternal
questions which which many people in
liberal modernity don't even think about
there has been a social breakdown in
decay and this brings me to a movie that
I would highly recommend it was supposed
to premiere at South by Southwest but
obviously that conference that's not
happening because China gave us a global
pandemic so instead it's airing on
Amazon Prime you can watch it if you
have Prime you can watch it for free the
movie is called twf nogf which is
internet slang for that feel when no
girlfriend and refers to a specific
internet mean and more broadly meme
culture of people who feel isolated and
alone and are kind of self-described
losers and just live in the bowels of
the internet it's a movie by the
filmmaker Alex Lee Moyer it's a first
movie so it's not not an A+ in terms of
the filmmaking it is actually very good
for a first film but the subject is so
important that I think you should check
it out it's a movie about alienated
young men the the so called in cells or
the losers or the people that the left
think are going to be all the future
school shooters and the the racists and
the bigots and the terrible people and
the movie is pretty even-handed about
them and it really shines a pretty
pretty clear and critical light on these
guys how much these guys are serious how
much they're being ironic how technology
and ideology and liberalism and modern
society and individualism and social
breakdown has led to this phenomenon and
what it means for all of us so obviously
the title refers to what you'd say
self-described losers right this
depressive feeling when you don't have a
girlfriend and you can't do anything and
you're not going anywhere
and it diagnoses all of these ills that
diagnosis broken families diagnoses the
feeling of meaninglessness that a lot of
people have in modernity diagnoses the
breakdown of friendship and romantic
relationships so people don't have type
real-life relationships with people so
they just go online and find communities
of people some of whom are just as
isolated and met
stuff as they are but it's it's that
virtual relationship which is not really
the sake and it can be nice I have
virtual relationships with people but
having a in-person physical tangible
real-life relationship with somebody is
a different thing and if it means
something different a breakdown of
social cohesion as a whole the hypocrisy
and an absurdity of political
correctness you know one thing that a
lot of the figures in this movie talk
about they're like they say that we're
you know bigots and racists and sexist
we're just joking it's just a joke it's
we're just being ironic here because our
politically correct culture is so
intense now that people need an outlet
to transgress taboos young people always
want to transgress taboos you know if
this were I don't know 10 20 years ago
these would be the emo kids if this were
30 years ago these would be the Punk
kids it's people who feel like they
don't quite fit into society and in
create the trouble with modern societies
increasingly more and more people feel
like they don't fit in because that
social cohesion has objectively and
steadily and aggressively broken down
part of it is the irony you know we live
in a society that's very ironic that's
very cynical
everything is ironic and cynical right
every everything is sort of sarcastic if
you look at old forms of entertainment
it's very earnest it's very up and peppy
and happy and you know think of like
Ricky Ricardo I remember I was when I
was in Cuba I saw a performance there
and it I was struck by how earnest it
was people were very enthusiastic
because our pop culture in America today
is very ironic and lethargic and
everything's too-cool-for-school and
everyone's kind of kind of popularly
depressed that tells us something about
the culture and then the ugliness of it
that's the other thing that you just
look at certain towns you look at
certain media you look at look all
around us and our modern culture is ugly
the architecture is ugly the paintings
are ugly the music is ugly the fashion
is ugh it's just ugly we don't have a
sense of beauty or order anymore and
that that aesthetic reality what we can
see with our own eyes has a relationship
to our ideology as a relationship to
what we believe to be true about the
eternal questions when a society
just worships sex for sex own sake then
it's it's not gonna be sensuous and and
alluring and beautiful it's gonna be
pornographic when a society just values
things to be consumed as commodities
then we're gonna open retail shops
before we open churches right it's an
ugly thing it's really worth taking a
look at this movie I think it will open
your eyes not even just to this one
segment of the Internet this one segment
of disaffected young men it will open
your eyes to some of the problems in our
American Psycho society as a whole
that's our show I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show see tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there